il s'a doumbia tient il à face et ap bep
froid et climatisation
mais comment celui un moment dans sa
scolarité
moi tu vois ce que je trouve c'est le
froid c'est pas parce que c'est quand
les gens tu vois semble bien ils ont
froid j'aime bien la clim
excusez moi madame la conseillère
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire quand on aime
le froid bepc ap climatisation c'est
très bien c'est un métier qui gagnent
bien vous préviens je sai baba vous avez
bien fait de venir
[Applaudissements]
ah oui j'ai compris sa numéro de mime
donc il peut pas parler alors ils savent
où aller me met des choses
d'accord et on va essayer de trouver de
quoi il s'agit d'accord vous allez c'est
trouver quelqu'un me maïssa attention
merci j'en vends déjà un attendant les
restos merci merci
alors vous allez nous brimer à un
premier truc et s'est trouvée attention
s'ils voulaient vraiment faire cette
surprise à omar pas c'est tout simple un
c'est juste un petit truc
il
ce qu'il a fait mais c'est tout ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cette note est salée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un problème que sur ceux de ses
valeurs alors sachez que ça va être la
nouvelle formule de motus attention
troisième 3ème action dix ans qu'on dit
moi je pense à tout ça les bouchons
baisse la vitre et mais cela reste un
but d'un la voiture serait dans les
bouchons
[Applaudissements]
ouais ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon
la lola et ses hobbies badminton rugby
théâtre et cinéma accrobranche ou la
fait de l'accrobranche ou il faut que la
manche qu'elle soit là
parler c'est mon ami la crau et dans la
cour
[Applaudissements]
j'arrive sur martin on se plaît elle à
changer tarzan
on va prendre l'ascenseur qui va prendre
l'escalier ne prend l'ascenseur
escaliers quoi et voulez-vous
l'ascenseur si les mots oui c'est du
cinquième étage où ça l'autre la riva
il y aura une tarte le premier arrivé en
bas aura le droit de mettre la tarte
dans la tête de l'autre d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il allait à l'essai
il dit
attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la tendance haussière bb assortie d'un
censeur scène john kerry c'est le jeu
qui vous jouez les jeunes salariés les
jours je voit le jour tiers
[Applaudissements]